still looking for an unusual gift for
someone well the u.s. Forest Service
might be able to help you there for as
little as $25 how about that the
government will sell you a wild horse
though the animals come with a few
requirements that not everyone can
fulfill John Blackstone has the story
in a remote windswept corner of Northern
California Megan high-note and her kids
have come to get a horse at the double
Devil Garden Corral with a lot to choose
from Megan got the horse she always
wanted
she's a Carmel oh so she's a solid she
got this mare at the right price it's a
great deal we have some amazing horses
available at the devil devil well doors
curls the horses held in Devil's garden
are managed by the u.s. Forest Service
and they need homes that's why Kevin
Sandusky is selling hard there are
currently over two hundred and forty
horses here of all ages sizes colors the
horse of your dreams is in this corral
right now during summer round ups on
government land a thousand wild horses
were removed but there are more than
4,000 horses grazing here on the rocky
plateau when we met Ken Sandusky last
year he pointed to the impact they're
having how high should this be there's
some examples around here where it's
probably three or four inches but when
it gets graze right down to the to the
nub there there's just no vegetation
left and you can see how they're just
dying out ranchers who lost their leases
to graze cattle here sued to reduce the
number of horses on the land wild horse
advocates are also suing arguing the
horses are iconic and could be sold for
slaughter most Americans love horses and
they don't want to see America's iconic
wild horses rounded up and sold for
human consumption abroad efforts to
appease both sides have fallen to the
Forest Service on open house tours and
on social media there is plenty to look
at by anyone who would be a good fit
you would have a year before you receive
title on that horse
and in that time you'll be asked to show
that you are taking good care of that
horse the facility requirements the
murse means a 20 by 20 enclosure and a
walk-in barn a three sided barn
Megan high-note has all that on the
ranch she helps manage in Oregon today's
purchase is the second horse she adopted
from the devil Devils garden the horses
here are believed to be descendants of
domesticated horses but generations of
living on their own have made them wild
and now the challenges to tame them this
is definitely by diamond-in-the-rough
this will be my next couple years and
she says it won't be her last for CBS
this morning Saturday John Blackstone in
San Francisco yeah the issue is not how
much you spent it's taken care of yeah
the right yeah I know I'm not getting
either one of you
you